Okay guys, let's dive into the rest, let's kind of just presume.
We're gonna have to no doubt put our famous indicator back on.
That doesn't have its default settings.
At this point, I should already know this off by hop.
Okay, it's a mid-night, 7 to 10, 2 to 5. Cool, it is now the first of July.
We are bullish. No, we're not. No, we are.
We just shifted these lows.
We're shorted here. We're shorted again here.
We're closed the position here or somewhere in here, like 5 or something.
And we shifted back to bullish and we are bullish. So we're looking for longs.
I would expect price to be back into here. This London, do we have any news?
First of July.
Inflation rate and ISM.
Whilst London low is like this, I expect Asia to be taken as well. That's
inflation rate done.
And yeah, that's ISM. Cool.
Still bullish, there's that gap fill. That's what we want to see. So we're
still looking for longs.
We need to check if this is accurate, but
this is where it all, it all comes down to this price level.
So we're still bearish in the M1. Probably not going to get trade.
Tuesday, 2nd of July. Inflation rate and Powell.
Now a bearish. That's a shift.
But does it close? It does.
So we will need to be cautious here because inflation rate is at 5 and it's now
4. So an hour
before, obviously it is your own news, so it might not be as impactful. If I
was trading this,
I'd be looking really for this area.
The long target is up here.
I do want to be cautious of this inflation rate. So we'll see how management
comes in.
Again, that is a tag, obviously that's where I would be in the market.
So I'd put my stops to break even pretty much, especially if we have inflation
rate heading up.
But my stop would at least go below this low. So from a $17,000 stop
to a $2,200 stop.
And that's a break even. Well, not break even. It's actually a small loss.
And again, solid management.
Yeah, I think that makes sense.
So instead of taking a, you know,
a 1% loss,
we take 0.2% loss.
It sounds accurate.
It's actually didn't hold it through the news either because it was out of the
trade before the news came.
This is a
a very good news.
So we have power speech at 9.30. So probably I don't want to hold through that.
That's power speech. Yeah.
It's still no, it's still a bit no trade anyway.
But that's a nice surprise action if we can stay in here now.
Okay, it's a nice surprise action, internal pro trend.
That's not a shifter. No. London.
It's a lot of liquidity down here.
Again, the larger the level, the more I will be willing to expand the area that
I'm looking at.
Obviously, I'm looking at the accumulation area.
It's kind of like accumulation, manipulation, recumulation, distribution.
That's what we're looking at. It's still only a four and a half hip stop.
Wait, it's going to need a decent amount of legs
to trade towards the target.
How did you lie? 3 a.m. Nothing.
Probably no tag. That's a session done.
So we could get a nice New York set up here.
Yeah, we can kind of come back into this area.
Nope. Well, I'll catch them all.
Still bullish, 4th of July, which is, I'm pretty sure, bank holiday.
Nope. New York, probably dead.
Still bullish. Again, no lungs in here. We need to sweep Asia low.
Hmm.
We have a pullback fail to break.
Then we'll go back to the height point, have one candle.
Technically, it's not a pullback.
That's FOMC, right? Oh, no. Friday the 5th, NFP.
Okay, this really horrible price action. I don't have a bias for that day.
I would rather just not do anything. I'll let the market decide.
Okay. So we continue bullish. Again, don't know how to trade this.
I don't know where I would consider my lows probably here.
The horrible, horrible price action would much rather just sideline.
London session. So we'll be longing if the opportunity is present.
So, I'm going to go back to the next one.
I'm going to be in the market for that.
And there's pretty much no chance getting into a position anyway.
That'd be the confirmation and then, boom, expectation.
Again, this type of price action, like, just don't be scared to do absolutely
nothing.
You don't have to force a trade. It's what
won two components of third day of price action. You don't have to force
anything.
I would rather sit on my hands and do absolutely nothing.
Wednesday the 10th of July. We had FedPel again, but 10.
Nothing. London session. So still looking for longs at this point.
So, that may be a long
okay, where's the M1 structure here.
So, technically that's the opportunity. Thursday 11th.
Inflation rates in New York session.
Not a huge fan.
And no tech.
Difficult to read price action to return to New York session. Obviously not
interested in
this specific New York session.
Again, also even structure, to be honest.
Like, that's now the swing high.
Yeah, that's just obviously untradable.
It's got some London. Friday 12th of July. What do we have?
Where is a, well, PPI.
Sweep of lows. So, the problem here is that I can already see, could be wrong,
but it looked
like this is the M1 structure.
And I am wrong, which is a good thing.
So, that's the problem. So, that's the problem. So, that's the problem. So,
that's the problem.
So, I think the, we're still bearish until we take these highs. I'm going to,
obviously, double triple check. So, I didn't thoroughly check, but
trying to make sure.
So, that's the problem. So, that's the problem. So, that's the problem. So,
that's the problem.
So, that's the problem. Yeah.
Okay. So, we are bearish. So, we need to see that high get taken.
That's the high that's going to take them. At which point?
Three fifty five. How would I know this?
That's the only set opportunity that there is in my eyes.
And that's over. And then New York, eight thirty, we have PPI. So, I want to be
in for that,
which is that. And then,
Friday 12th, we have Michigan consumer. Untradable, which takes us to here.
So, we're still bullish. We're still in this deliberated annoying, sometimes
when you can't
get in these moves, but it's not much you can do about it. Sometimes you have
periods where
you just everything runs smoothly. Sometimes you have periods where you just
can't seem to get
into the market. Equal lows. And why does it do that? Okay. Well, I wouldn't
have been able to
trade New York. I don't know. That's not bearish. I wouldn't have been able to
trade New York.
We break structure here.
One, two. That's a pullback. Yeah, we are bearish. It's a pullback. That's a
continuation.
That's a high. That's a low. We have highs in Asia high again, which is for me,
just like,
no. That shows the bullish, at that point, is obviously not a sell. Tuesday 16
th of July,
we have retail sales at 830. That's retail sales. So, we bearish again, which
is honestly
probably why I would have expected anyway. And when probably I'm going to get a
trade.
Nope. And now I'm bullish again. Again, honestly, typically, June, July, you
will see
you will see more choppy price action than in other periods. Purely just off
the basis of
it's summer. The summer months, they are more difficult to trade. At least that
's what I found
historically. People are already doing like the beginning of the year was
decent. People are
already complaining about Trump, when an actuality is Trump isn't the issue.
430.
Nothing.
Again, this entire period has just been difficult. This was a mess until we
broke out. And then
when we break out, we enter into this is clean. This is clean. This is a mess.
But like I said, it only takes one of these trades to play out
cleanly that makes up for it. You only need a couple of winning trades a month.
People underestimate that, underestimate the power of that.
It's pointless.
Do you want to try it? Next day, 18s. We have
interest rate decisions for the European Central Bank in New York.
We've technically swept Asia low here, which I'm not a huge fan of, but
this is probably a reversal in there as well.
So it's just a really hard price action.
Okay.
Everyone.
No, it is not the clearly's price action, obviously.
So, we're going to be doing it.
All of that for that. I should have probably just played price action first.
Okay.
It's fourth, I'm not going to enter a trade until price starts coming back.
And price starts coming back.
Objectically speaking.
Right at the end of London, the risk reward isn't there.
I could try and play with the start loss.
It's more aggressive.
We'll try. I've been a little bit aggressive with my start loss. That may
hinder me, may help me.
I don't really know. That's my start loss.
Okay. We're going to get a bunch of news in a minute as well.
That's still technically being the trade, but that's going to get run probably.
Yeah, so it doesn't really matter. Not my favorite set up.
Okay.
That's the end of news for US, but there's just no chance.
Perfect. That's the data.
Okay.
.
Horrible, horrible price action.
Okay.
Okay. Let's see if we get another set up maybe.
What day is this? 22nd? There's no news. We'll just check.
Really, just scrappy price action, to be honest.
Okay.
Second attempt at the same set up.
We're really going again on the same set up.
Maybe.
I don't know what to enter in the end or on this point.
This is all liquidate to me.
Metagated. Metagated.
We couldn't use this, which we're already inside of.
That's not even a 1 to 2, like how am I supposed to trade that?
It's 1 to 2. I don't know how to trade it.
There's no news apparently as well.
We can try again in New York, but I don't know how to trade that.
And straight through.
That's technically tradable.
But only if there's a reversal. Get me out of this price action, please.
No, we're still in the exact same price, like.
It's 23rd, still no news, 23rd, 22nd, 23rd, still no news.
That could be reversal.
At this point, I really have no idea whether I'm one structure as well.
I'm going to assume that it's like the
I can see it's like that, obviously.
Yeah, that's a reversal. I don't like it, but it's like at all.
Yeah, I mean, pretty much. Web prices tag does, I guess.
Really not a fan of this price action, but the liquidity on the sell side is
crazy.
This entire leg is horrible.
The swing structures for try it. 23rd, apparently no news.
And out, crazy. Before our journal, let's see if we get another one.
I would really prefer if we didn't.
Like, can we just trade low already?
Thank you.
They're both breaks, so man, it's back to back to back to back losses.
That's like four losses in a row of five in a row, I think.
Horrible price action. We're definitely in drawdown for this period.
And when you're risking 1% of starting balance as well, that was a crazy amount
of buses in a row.
That's such horrible price action.
Again, this is where your own personal
testing and stuff will come in as well. I will be able to come in if I'm doing
my own independent
testing, for example, not just like I'm doing right now, and come into an area
of price like
this or an area of price that we had before. I can add an extra setup, for
example, here,
add a new category. And that new category would basically be subjective opinion
.
And I could add a take or avoid, right, plain and simple, take or avoid,
and then give my reasoning as to why. And then I can test the data for that as
well.
Then I can understand, like, for example, those trades taken just now, like, I
would have avoided
every single one of them. And if I can give the reasoning and the
characteristic behind it
as well, then I can start kind of, then I can start organizing that into
principle that I
can follow, if it's repeatable. The trend is unknown, should be a,
I don't even know what's going on here, genuinely.
Like it's crazy.
Well, at least we're out of that.
24th. Now we begin to have a news. We have H-COBA 3.0, which, honestly, I don't
want to
trade through.
Oh, don't give me this again.
Right.
a
still head loss from that last period, and just completely skip for it. Just
give me the
context of you wondering what I'm doing. Obviously, you should probably already
know, but you don't.
Wait, I'm 15 bearish. We, Frankfurt has swept above
Asia session high, and the reversal has come in London session. So it's a
Frankfurt sweep,
reversal, and entry. I would just be looking at
buy to sell.
Which is pretty much the M15 level.
It tags in.
That would be my move stops above the high, at least takes a $17,000 stop down
to
$3400 stop because, like, most of the risk of
I would like to go to break even as well. So we're starting on this as here.
That pretty much sums up
July, doesn't it?
$3.15
Wednesday, 24.
Oh, that's my bad.
That's my bad.
That's Hitchcock.
Well, we'd have a break even anyway, so it's not that big of a deal.
Again, being that close to stuff when Hitchcock is in, it's only a 2.9.
Yeah, it is. Well, it is.
But it does just about sum up.
July, honestly, in a nutshell.
No, that sums up July in a nutshell.
Well,
let's keep the ball rolling.
Okay, New York.
Nothing, apparently.
Now we're at a point of interest.
So,
sometimes it's reasonably easy to understand where you're coming from because
it's the
lowest point, for example.
Sometimes it's really
more difficult to understand where your area of interest is.
Again, like, obviously, the only unmitigated area here is this inverter
there you go, but to expect pros to come all the way back down to here and
still respect
this and then trade away from there, it's just like wishful thinking.
I'd say that it couldn't.
That's not what I'm saying, but to believe having that as a principle on that
happening consistently is going to happen is wishful thinking.
I'm watching this scenario just well.
So we are down from our current balance, like,
like five, six percent in drawdown, I think, for this month.
But we're also getting to a point where 1% risk is like 1%, 1.6%, 1.7% of
original risk.
Again, you can do your own testing as well if you want to do set balance.
So kind of have it as it was that trade has already left the station.
The irrigation of that February gap was the only unmitigated area of price.
Didn't even catch it.
Might as well remove it at this point, 4.10.
Okay, New York.
25th, durable goods in GDP, no, avoid.
Yeah, that's not, doesn't give the reversal.
They're going to go for these periods in the, in the live market as well.
So I'm glad that you get to see it firsthand because it's easy to be a great
trader when
everything is going well.
But what's going to either kind of make or break you is how you deal with
difficult periods because it's your ability to follow your rules,
stick to your plan and not deviate in the difficult periods that are going to
have
the biggest impact on your trading in general because you can have a great run.
You know, you've traded for two months, you've returned 20% in those two months
,
everything has been clean, crisp.
You've passed a funded account.
You maybe passed two funded accounts.
Maybe you've got your first payout and then boom.
You hit a month and it's like this type of price action.
You come two pips away from your take profit and boom reverse, break even.
You take a trade, you get stopped out by two pips and then boom reverse, take
profit.
You read price immaculately, boom, no tag, price goes without you.
In those periods, are you still able to keep a level head and be like,
I follow my rules, I stick to the plan and that's what actually matters.
Or do you start deviating?
Do you start trying to seek revenge on the market?
Do you start chasing trades, taking trades that don't fit your plan?
You get tagged out by a couple pips and you see price start reversing again in
your direction
and you start to get angry at the market, angry at yourself.
You're like, my stop loss was too tight.
I should have had it here, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, I'm getting in now and you go for another trade and then boom,
stop loss again, even though you shouldn't have it instead of taking 1% loss,
you take a 2% and they build up and that 20% that you had gets wiped out
in a month of trading on tilt and then you're left with your head in your hand
at the end of the
month thinking what on earth just happened?
It's deep because that's where a lot of traders end up and spend their time in
that cycle
because they're unable to regulate their emotions, they're unable to
just follow the basic rules of the plan without getting emotionally induced.
Like you're going to have difficult moments, but if you just have discipline
and you play a long
game, when you're focused on the long game, it's so much easier to make the
right decisions.
But you know when you're focusing on the short term game,
the I just got a fresh account, let me take my first payout so I can prove this
person that I
could really do with trading. I've struggled for years, now I've got my friend
that account,
now I'm going to get this payout to prove that to myself, to prove to that
person.
You'd bring in all of these unnecessary societal pressures, internal conflicts
and you don't even
realize it and then the trigger points of your kind of mismanagement of self
and then you're
at a crossroad because now what you have is a big gigantic mirror held up to
your face that shows
you your inefficiencies and your incompetence and now you have a choice. Do I
follow the
principle of pain plus reflection equals progress, which is the principle of
growth from radio,
the thing that I personally live my entire life from that one principle. I am
obsessed with
seeking the next level and growth and I understand the only way to do that is
by finding the painful
areas and looking at them and having radical self accountability to be the sole
, you know,
the person who's solely responsible for the outcome and then changing my
actions.
That's the path on the left. You take that path, you're going to achieve growth
,
eventually you're going to achieve success. You take the path on the right, you
look outside of
yourself, you blame, you blame the strategy, you blame the broker, you blame
the prop firm,
you blame me or a different mentor, right? Those that that path leads you to
doing the same thing
over and over and over again. So it's easy when it's easy. It's hard when it's
hard.
Do the right thing when it's hard and doing the right thing when it's easy will
be effortless.
I would like to use this opportunity to explain that
because this is difficult price action and in the live market, it's frustrating
even
in backtest and even if you're doing this in backtest and it's still going to
frustrate you.
We are human. We are not robots. We do have emotion. The purpose is, again, if
you haven't
been for the inner edge, I recommend going for that inner edge more times than
you can count.
It's not about not having emotions. It's not about being emotionless because we
're humans.
If your goal is to become emotionless, you're setting yourself up with
something unrealistic
and eventually you just start to hate your life, you'll start to resent trading
and you'll probably
give up. So you don't be emotionless. You be emotionally intelligent. You
become self-observant.
This is why you understand and learn meditation. This is why you journal. This
is why you reflect.
It's why you take care of your health. The one thing that people underestimate
the most is
their health. You don't have to understand my wife is a doctor. Not your
typical standard
kind of big pharma doctor, although she has degrees and she has a PhD. At some
point in time,
she took the route of root cause. She had this grandiose dream. She wanted to
change the world.
She wanted to help people, a woman's instinct. She went down the route. At some
point in time,
she goes for a realization that, hold on a minute, these institutions don't
want to
solve problems. They want to treat symptoms because solving the problem loses
the customer,
treating the symptom keeps them paying. If we solve everyone's problems, we
will have no business.
Let's just treat their symptoms and they'll keep coming back to us. She went
down the route of
a holistic approach at solving the root cause. She'll take all of your bloods.
It's magical
work, which she does. It's crazy. She'll take all of your bloods, all of your
profile and
of your blood and she'll look at all of your biomarkers and she'll understand
where all of
your problems are coming from. Please believe me when I tell you that so much
of our emotional
responsiveness and problems come from health. 90% of them come from health.
Your type of
person is always in fight or flight. Again, it becomes enhanced. The markets
enhance who you are.
Again, I know I'm kind of going on a rant here psychologically, but the markets
enhance who you
are, right? The market isn't good or bad. The same way that money isn't good or
isn't bad.
It's a neutral energy that amplifies its holder. So if you have money, it will
amplify who you are.
There are many bad people who get lots of money and do bad things with the
money.
There are many good people who get lots of money and go and do good things with
money
because money itself is neutral. It's not good nor bad. We're programmed as
kids and a lot of us.
Money is the root of all evil. If you're in the religious route, you may have
heard that before.
Money is the root of all evil or rich people aren't nice. The billionaires are
bad. When you
start to have these type of limiting beliefs, it becomes very difficult for you
to achieve any
levels of success financially because on one hand, I had this as myself. That's
why I'm sharing it.
And overcoming this limitation was one of the biggest things that unlocked so
much abundance in my life.
On one hand, I had this belief that the desire for money is bad and is evil and
is
ego and it's greed and it's all of these bad stigma things that they tell you
in the world.
And then you understand the world is controlled by a group of elites. I don't
disagree with that at all. It's very evident. You can go look at it up yourself
,
go look at the two largest firms in the entire world. Vanguard, Black Rock, go
look at who they're
owned by, go look at the families who are in the world. That's just common
knowledge at this point.
No longer is that stuff conspiracy. And because I understood that, I thought,
oh, well, maybe,
you know, money is bad. And only when I overcame that fallacy, it's a fallacy.
It's not even
limited belief. It's a fallacy. It's point blank, incorrect belief. Because I
also know a lot of
people in my life that have millions of dollars, tens of million dollars, some
even more that are
doing incredible things with their money, having a great impact. So money isn't
bad. All good,
it's neutral. The market isn't bad or good. It's neutral. It's just going to
reflect who you are.
So if you're someone who's constantly in a fight-off light, your nervous system
is just cracked from
years of drinking coffee or years of stimulation or years of chronic stress,
suppression of emotions,
all of these things, or maybe you have an abusive household growing up as a
child and you just
learn to be on constant fight-off light. I know what that's like. I can
resonate with that.
Then the market's going to reflect that back to you. And so it's very difficult
to trade in a place
of kind of homeostasis and neutrality when you're in that fight-off light. And
that can be very
evidently seen in your, for example, adrenal glands, right? Many people's adren
al glands
have just been ruined. And now everything becomes so much more amplified on
your nervous system.
Stress becomes even more stressful than it actually is because of your nervous
system.
That's directly correlated to health. And so I truly believe and, I mean, go
and look at all
of the billionaires in the world and go and look at how much they prioritize
health, right? Health
is over everything. Obviously going off on a bit of a rant there, but yeah,
yeah,
perfect opportunity to kind of drop some game in there because it's really,
really important, man.
Like trading is really an internal game. It really is. Cool. Let's keep running
. We're still bullish.
And so we don't want to be tagged into this.
Again, at this point, we're basically risking 1.7% of original starting capital
. So you can
do this however you would like to. Yeah, but it will still tell you your risk
to reward,
like the actual RR, for example, because each lot of risk is still one hour. So
we'll look at all
the data at the end. The risk to reward itself, the percentage return if
compounded, right?
Okay. So that's it. I'm going to go ahead and get started. I'm going to go
ahead and get started.
Friday 26, if we're going to have something, yeah, we have core PC personal
spending and personal
income. So we want to wait for that to pass. That's that.
Could trade the back of that. Technically, 842.
Yeah, the risk to reward isn't great.
The risk reward is like 1-2, not even to the target. So I think I'll just let
that kind of go.
Again, the risk reward still just, it's just not great. And that probably would
be a break even
anyway. Well, not probably. It would have been. Price still respected it, but
it still doesn't
matter. The risk reward is just not the one. Highs, lows, it doesn't break here
.
This is obviously difficult, but we're still bullish, so.
We're going for the lows. Okay, no, we're bullish. 29th, we don't have anything
, technically.
Probably not going to get a trade. No, don't insist. Expecting a lot of prices.
Not ideal price delivery to be honest with you, but here's what it is.
And it's the lows taken anyway.
Yeah, that'd be a better set up to take from there, to be honest with you.
If we get the shift, nope, 3-3, time is news. It's Friday, right? Not Tuesday.
We have...
Oh, well. Okay, we have a bunch, a bunch of news that's about to hit.
So, yeah. Honestly, don't want to be in that. Let me come back here. There's a
ridiculous
amount of news. It's a failure, right? Yeah. Inflation rate, GDP growth rate,
GDP growth rate,
growth rate, growth rate, growth rate, growth rate. So, that's all in London.
So, we'll see that
play out now. And that's all it constituted. All of that data, again, is
European news,
and then there's nothing for New York. We are obviously bearish. New York, that
's civil
London long sweep. What's that stretch about? Like, obviously bullish.
That's bearish.
Point of interest. Let's go stop moment 5M. The shift comes in here. Again,
what I'm looking
for here is the volume profile, really, in some sense. Like, I want to see the
order book and
the real accumulation of the positions is in this entire level. And the final
liquidation is
buy, loadout, sell. This here is most likely an inducement. So, this, the
entire range
is a white man, trust him, right? Even on the 500 time frame, we have, I want
to go,
my order blocks are always buy to sales. Now, sometimes, for example, if we
have a high here,
M price, for example, here, for example, comes in, pulls out, buys into this
high, and then sells
off. Then I want to use the buy to sell from that specific area. In this
scenario, you can see the
buy that takes the highs to sell is in here, which also constitutes the current
M5 value gap that we
have. They've already traded into, which is EU. Still only a four and a half
pip stop.
Again, I'm what I'm looking for.
I'm looking for this buy to sell range. That's where the actual momentum
takes place. And then from a profit level area, it's just continuation. And it
's one to six.
It's not a great risk to reward. To be for a swing target, I'd like, ideally,
you want to see these
lows as well, make this a much better quality setup, relative equal lows, Asia
and London.
I'll take some profit of these lows of five bar, getting price tag. And again,
we're tagging in,
not this inside bar. I hope for many people, where we're tagging this entire
range.
This is the bulk of the volume.
That's what we're interested in trading.
I wouldn't be so keen to go to breakeven yet.
Because this is still a fair value gap as well.
Or if I did, could scale in with a better risk to reward.
If I have the same risk open, for example, we're bearish. That's not a pullback
. That's a pullback
and a break. So if we were to, what's the risk to reward on that, for example?
I'm three. I'm two.
The risk reward doubles. So it's not a huge risk to reward.
It's crazy. Like, tight stops.
This isn't a huge risk reward, but this could become a huge risk reward.
The same trade idea. Instead of it being a one to six, could become a one to 13
.
If we're able to manage the risk aggressively, the issue becomes,
let's open this, the issue becomes a need to cut risk on this.
And if I move this to here, that's essentially breakeven.
But it's more aggressive because now if price does run up to this area
and continue trading down, I lose to 1%.
What is this trade currently up?
The trade's currently up 7,000.
If I close the trade
and put it above it again, it's still the risk.
I like the setup. The setup's dope, like, sweep of London high
into a strong point of interest. We have equal lows at Asia and London,
but that doesn't mean that I'm going to try and get involved in an aggressive
scalp
that just doesn't really make sense. That's just somewhat reckless trading, to
be honest with you.
It's just not worth it.
It could probably move stop to breakeven now.
But still scaling in. I don't really think it makes much sense.
That's the target I want to see. Hold on a second.
I know it was like 4.5 pips. That was here.
[pause]
Hmm. I would have got away with that, but it's still, I don't know, for me it's
just risky.
I didn't trade that at all. No.
That's, I think that pretty much brings us back to breakeven.
30th of July, have one more day, a bunch of news again.
The world is not going to get another trade off the back of that.
[pause]
Another solid New York position.
Last day, but there's heavy news again. For euro.
Inflation rate, you're on year.
I mean, now we're bullish. Probably not going to get along.
And that's July. Honestly, pretty difficult week. Probably brought our win rate
down a bit.
Down to 40% win rate. So a little bit of look at the data.
Now what we're seeing is average losing trade increased, average winning trade
decreased,
I think. Probably have a lower profit factor now.
Yep. Zella scores higher somehow. Probably higher consistency.
Maybe recovery factor, because that was a drawdown period.
We went like that's, that's the longest drawdown we've had.
If we look at risk to reward, so instead of looking at it from a percentage
perspective,
I'm not sure why our win rate does that.
I'm not sure what's going on with the data there.
It just cuts off most of our winners. I'm not sure why it's even doing that.
Maybe that's trades that have only run to their full take profit.
That's five. That's five.
Yeah, something, this thing's tripping out.
Okay, but I think this is probably accurate.
So 62.5 R instead of just looking at it from a compounding perspective,
because from a 70, we're at 73%, because we're compounding our returns.
But if we look purely based off of an arm wall perspective, it's 62.6 R.
So we have done February, March, April, May, June, and July now, so six months,
62.5 R.
So average over 10 R at the moment. But if you're compounding an account, which
most of you
probably aren't, then the cumulative returns is like 73%. Cool. Let's run over
into August,
and let's keep the ball rolling.